luz verde para la campaña de vacunación
contra el cob y 19 en europa esto horas
después de la autorización de la agencia
europea del medicamento
la comisión europea respalda así la
distribución de la vacuna desarrollada
por facer y buy and tech
la agencia europea del medicamento ha
evaluado minuciosamente esta vacuna y ha
concluido que es segura y eficaz contra
el cob y 19 factor facundo affranchino
las primeras valoraciones tendrán lugar
entre el 27 y el 29 de diciembre la
prioridad serán los más vulnerables los
adultos mayores y el personal sanitario
antes de una campaña de vacunación más
grande el objetivo de la unión europea
es distribuir 200 millones de dosis de
aquí a septiembre de 2021
ésta estará disponible para todos los 27
países miembros al mismo tiempo y
proveerá una base científica sólida para
el desarrollo de los programas de
vacunación y para un marco continuo de
control y supervisión de las vacunas
station of the vaccines es una
aceleración del calendario que llega
después de la presión de varios países
como alemania que criticaron como muy
lento el proceso de autorización en
reino unido y eeuu la vacuna de facer y
vayan tec de se administra desde hace
tres semanas pero la emergencia
sanitaria ha crecido de la mano de una
nueva cepa del cob y 19 que apareció en
el territorio británico la agencia
europea del medicamento afirma que no
tiene ninguna prueba que señale que la
actual vacuna no funcione contra la
nueva variante
el laboratorio pagantes se comprometió a
estudiar en los próximos días esa
mencionada nueva cepa